Libraries are centers of information. They are where we store the collective memories of the human species.
And
therefore they protect the history of the Arctic
after man started interacting
with the Arctic - first the idea and then
the reality of it, and later the loss of
it.
So I think libraries will be among the most important places we have
in making people aware of what climate change means
and that it is actually
happening.
And the Arctic as a reference point
is invaluable because that is
where we see it most clearly.
That is the climate change and its effects on this
planet.
And on human life because we
should never forget that the edge
of the Arctic - the Arctic Circle - has been
a home for human beings for millennia
and the new story is of course how the
people who have lived there are losing
their homes, their hunting grounds and
the place they call home.
So I hope that
story is also in the archives
because the fate of the people who live by the
Arctic
is about the fate of humankind.